good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Monday hope everybody
had an amazing weekend a weekend filled
with family friends laughter and joy and
and speaking of a family a friend a
laughter and a joy it's Jackie O hi turd
and Lou screw yes I had a weekend full
of the big four because my house was the
location for streis Fest 2023
now at a glance now that it's behind you
give us I know we were all keeping up on
your stories with you know how the Bros
were co-mingling coexisting but you know
after four days together tell us it was
a beautiful weekend and I would say the
theme of the weekend if I could only use
one word to describe it was Harmony
it was really beautiful of course they
started out ice cold not even
challenging each other just like
completely unparalleled tracks and over
the days the ice between the stripes
brother and thawed and it was beautiful
to behold by the time they left last
night it was just like weapons down
daytime I mean they weren't being like
those Cavaliers that you see on reels
that are like
spooning each other they weren't doing
that they'll never and they'll never be
that no but you could tell that they
were comfortable with the other's
presence and I feel like someone who
contributed a lot to them mending fences
was Harry
because Harry really brought far into
the fold like Harry is obsessed with
Theo he calls him PHA and now we all
call him thought like when I say say
Theo he does say like fee but now we all
call him father that like Theo's name is
just far moving forward he will be here
to four known to as far yes so Harry is
obsessed with Pho like fathers father
that like coming down the hallway
Theo like doesn't give a and
Bruno's had to
really look inside himself
to accept these facts you know and I
think Jackie he said to look inside
himself to accept these foxes
and I think it made him realize how he's
been a little selfish you know yeah and
it's like Harry Bruno loves Harry Harry
loves Spa fa loves
who I don't know no it's literally the
move that movie and like with Julia
Roberts and it's like and who's chasing
you nobody
no I mean what movie is that like my
best friend's wedding or whatever maybe
I don't think I've seen the whole thing
me neither but I know that scene where
it's like she's chasing a guy who's
chasing another girl and she's calling
her friend she's like I'm chasing him
and she's like and who's chasing you and
it was honestly such a sleigh it's like
nobody go home wench you're desperate
technically in the three that I'm
describing you are chasing Bruno I was
chasing Bruno but Bruno's always so good
to his mommy but anyways it really was
lovely father was a pleasure to have the
house was jumping all weekend obviously
jump jump he doesn't jump a lot but I
think it was a good energy for him to be
surrounded by a lot of positivity and
fun
he came home you know like lighter than
air I cannot thank you enough for
watching my boy like you know how I mean
I know you know the importance of having
a safe space to leave your son like of
course and so just to know he was
completely loved and taken care of
and it's really something I never have
to worry about because I'm always just
leaving Theo at my in-laws and I never
even look back like I know Theo so taken
care of but they were otherwise occupied
this weekend I was kind of in a pickle
and I felt bad I'm like you know you're
literally like 100 years pregnant you
have a one and a half year old you have
a bit a dog I'm like is this kind of
like an imposition but I felt good about
it I thought you know maybe it might be
but it really wasn't it was lovely
honestly I feel like I should add
another dog ah I feel like that's what
Harry needs but Brew brew like he said
this was temporary he said I was okay
with it because I knew there was an end
no by the way Bruno would run away from
home
if it was a permanent solution a few
times in Florida I thought about getting
a second dog because I thought actually
that's what Brew would want like wanted
I thought maybe he was a little lonely
but then I realized like my crazy
jealous boy could never share Mommy
no and I think that's why Bruno and I
really kind of get along and see one
another we're both like incredibly
self-centered
um selfish borderline
um like attention-seeking people yeah
but just like his anti-coya Bruno is so
true so loyal so loving so wonderful so
steadfast like he has all these amazing
qualities and his Achilles heel he's
just jealous like yeah if it's just the
one thing I can allow it none of us are
perfect human beings yeah it's so true
well I am back in the city and I drove
home from The Hamptons yesterday and Ben
and I actually listened to Friday's
episode of the toast in the car and let
me just say like Ben like really never
sits down and listens to the toast I
don't want to get into it it's so
hurtful
um when I tell you this man was
cackling and I also never really
listened to our episodes like sometimes
I'll watch them but like really never I
like to just leave it on the on the mic
and move on to the next day what a
delight we are oh my God I was cackling
at the Blaze Pizza man I was cackling at
us trying to make the writer strike
about us hoping you know hopefully uh
getting smart list canceled and off the
Airways like we are truly talented
That's so exciting I should listen to
the episode because by now I have no
idea what was said like it's been yes
it's been so long it would be like
listening to two other girls yeah no
that's the thing like I can never listen
to the episode that we record that day
I'm like I just lived it like I know
what's coming next out of my mouth but
when you don't know what I'm gonna say I
guess that's what other people
experience when they listen to this
podcast oh my God we are it's a journey
we who knows what the is gonna come
out of our mouth yeah that's so so
that's so fun who was Ben laughing more
at like you or me honestly you really
yeah maybe it's because I thought that
was like a delusional question to ask no
no like honestly you I forget what it
was that you said but he was like you
know something's funny when like
somebody repeats it like 10 seconds
later yeah they're like laugh and then
they're like smartless is canceled party
or whatever that's something
yeah
I said that but I couldn't remember what
it was but he was like really and then
when it was over he was like should we
listen to another one but then we were
getting close to the city and I had some
phone calls to make so I was like no
that is hysterical I shall do that one
time and then when people whenever I do
like meet and greets or I meet toasters
in the wild they're like oh my God I'm
always listening to you on like my road
trips it made the car ride go by so fast
I'm like discovering podcasts for the
first time
no but it really did like it was such a
long ride and it was Sunday so there was
so much traffic oh my God it breathes
right by that's amazing so that's the
good news from the weekend the bad news
is that I think we have to accept
defeat that we're not gonna need
smartless because we had our chance on
Friday I sent Claudia a screenshot smart
list was number one with their Max tag
Mark episode which if you watched their
docu-series like that was that the show
Tanked right it's a flop episode it's a
flop episode smart list was number one
we were number two
and we never traded places and by the
way I checked on Saturday night because
I was with Hannah burner and you know
she's a podcast girl and I was telling
her you know our current Mission and she
thought it was hilarious and I checked
on Saturday night we were still number
two to uh to MIT boy whose name I cannot
recall so we stood there for a while we
we almost did it and I know a lot of
people switched from Spotify to Apple
and we can't nobody said yeah that's
what I'm saying I feel like so many of
our listeners like join forces like we
put our heads together and we were going
up against like one of their worst
episodes and like we still couldn't hack
it no I mean the only hope moving
forward is that they don't release
episodes because of the SAG strike and I
was talking to Josh Peck yeah that was
like I was commenting what does that
mean for Josh Peck so I'm not entirely
sure but it does
it does
apply like there are certain things you
cannot do so
I don't know if that means I don't think
smartlist will stop releasing episodes
all together but they're definitely not
going to be like exciting and like
Hollywood juicy the only thing that
maybe I could say about the max tag Mark
episode it was like maybe it actually
because it flopped like more people it
was this more people were curious to
listen to it to like hear what did so
bad in Boston that night
perhaps like we're talking about it so
true we've got to stop talking about it
yeah I feel like we're kind of making it
Buzzy no this whole episode this whole
conversation is counterintuitive like we
are hyping up the thing in which we are
seeking to destroy so true but we're
just such like positive forces so true
we're forces for good we can't we're
good faith actors
totally
I love a Monday show we haven't had you
know pop culture stories since Friday
and the Friday ones were within us today
we had pop culture stories on Friday no
Jackie we were still hysterical when I
was listening to the podcast like that's
the thing about the Fast Five like it
doesn't Define us they're irrelevant
first of all second of all the stories
today are five I couldn't even tell you
which one which is excited to talk about
yeah no and I think like this happens a
lot um just in it's the line the nature
of the work that we do like you talk a
lot for so many weeks and like you
definitely feel burnout like every
couple of months and the summer is
always like kind of a slow time for
business and so
I was maybe on the verge of a burnout
but listening to this episode it was
even like one of our best episodes
Jackie I'm reinvigorated I was like
thinking all night last night like what
funny jokes am I gonna make oh my God
but what if you like him jinxed it now
that you know like your greatness
so true you know maybe we were just like
so oblivious before
right we didn't even know how great we
were and now that we know like we're
gonna destroy it like everything changed
it
yeah well let's not like be negative
like that I know that's like your thing
these days but that's not you're so
funny like I say one negative comment
I said one positive thing last week and
then
you're like oh one thing about me like
I'm gonna exaggerate like I am going to
like the pendulum is gonna swing I'm not
a consistent person I'm the biggest
hypocrite like nothing I say ever lines
up with what I said the day before
that's why when people are like Claudia
I can't believe you did this when you
said yesterday like have we met I'm
literally the least consistent person
none of my views are consistent like
they all cross-reference they all like
muck each other up like leave me alone
yeah which serves you when you go to
listen to an episode from four days ago
because you have no idea what you said
oh my God that's like somebody tagged me
in this Tick Tock yesterday somebody
posted like I guess like a few years ago
I went on a rant about Lululemon and now
all I wear is Lululemon they're
like Claudia you said they were like too
expensive okay and I like them now so
what are you gonna do about it like
because I like it did you not get the
viral sound because I like it right like
okay now that person do one about
reading do one about Downton
pickleball
right like stop holding me to things
I've said like I I do not want to be
held accountable I don't know me like I
do not it depends on the mood that I'm
in like I do not associate with
different versions of myself like I can
only be truly held accountable for this
very moment you're constantly changing
constantly growing and evolving and if
people and isn't that what we see isn't
that what we search for if people can't
understand that then that's on them it's
not a me problem they can go be stagnant
over there
liking the same things forever
couldn't be made worse disliking the
same things forever yeah at least have
open I'm slow but I'm open she's slow
but she's open that's so me name of my
next book
slow but mud it's smut slope it
literally sounds like smut slow but open
yeah are you reading anything right now
oh Ben was cackling at us coming up with
a smut book for sagafra versus Disney
that's funny except did you see what
Fran Drescher said about Bob Iger
I did she called him repugnant gorgeous
word I feel like she said what he said
was repugnant she did she did and she
said it was very out of touch she didn't
mince words and she also like it was
obviously like an unprompted question
and the way she just kind of like she
slayed that answer like Bob Iger will
never recover Bob biker is quaking but I
just want to say it kind of reiterates
the fact that this is the start of the
smut book like that there was such high
tension she's in the Press calling him
repugnant then they have to get into the
room together and he's like this is the
woman who called me your pugman she's
like this is the man that I find
repugnant and then they have to put
their heads together and work together
and and somebody on um our
Instagram left a comment for what that
we couldn't come up with a really good
name for the book and they came up with
the best one I'm so sorry I don't know
your name I will um
you know forever be indebted to you but
it's called happily ever after
[Laughter]
so good
that is so fun
it's a perfect title for today's episode
oh that too yeah I mean who knows we we
haven't even cracked the Fast Five I
know but I do really like that yeah
because I like it
okay well I feel like we could get into
the stories because there's a lot to
discuss yeah I'm down and we're gonna
recap the first three episodes of Summer
I Turned Pretty correct
yes I did watch them last night and I
have some thoughts I watched two and a
half episodes which is enough
to participate to participate and you
can spoil it for me so without further
Ado here are the fast five stories that
you need to know
and the fast five stories that you need
to know are brought to you by skims you
guys already know that we love skims it
all started with their fits everybody
collection of the butteriest underwear
ever so we wanted to try more from the
brand we're always seeing their cotton
loungewear all over our Instagram feeds
so we have to see for ourselves what all
the hype was about and let me tell you
they did not disappoint they are the
cutest and most flattering sets you will
find for in or out of the house so I
have the cotton brief I have the T-shirt
I actually wore the T-shirt to like a
photo shoot last week and it looked so
snatched and cute everyone was and it
was just like not something I would
normally wear skims is always just like
encouraging me to push the boundaries of
what I can and should wear and I've
always been a big fan of their bras and
undies I'm wearing one of the bras right
now they're relaxation bras their
t-shirt bras they're creating the next
generation of loungewear for everybody
not you casually dropping that you had a
photo shoot
yeah no I did had a thank you for
picking that up what I was putting down
I did have a photo shoot yes it was more
of like a video shoe you know secret
project Vibes
um I tried the cotton t-shirt from skims
it is the best T-shirt I have ever owned
I'm really picky about like the fit of
my t-shirts I hate when it rides up or
if you wear it like a bunch then it gets
misshapen
but the skims t-shirt is a game changer
it hugs my body perfectly so the search
for the perfect t-shirt is over also um
it's their most tagged collection the
general cotton collection so it's made
with the classic cotton fabric for
comfortable everyday wear it's made with
Ultra Soft and natural fiber so the
cotton collection features elevated
Lounge pieces designed for Comfort
indoors and out they are available in
sizes extra extra small to 4X so believe
the hype skims is over a hundred
thousand five star reviews for a reason
the cotton collection and more are
available now at skims.com plus get free
shipping on orders over 75 after you
place your order be sure to let them
know that we sent you so select podcast
in the survey and select the toast in
the drop down menu that follows today's
episode is also brought to you by Thrive
Market our go-to for all of our organic
grocery and household essentials and the
convenience of getting it all quickly
shipped to our doorstep is of course a
huge Time Saver as Thrive Market members
we save money on every single grocery
order on average we save 30 each time
obviously once you become a mother you
really need to like have groceries
docked in the house all the time and
that's why I'm always at Jackie's house
like munching on things you need all
kinds of things snacks and you want
healthy items too like you want the
organic
cheddar crisps right and Thrive has
everything and everything is so healthy
so you don't have to like start trolling
the grocery aisles like looking at all
the ingredients for everything and like
trying to figure out what's bad for you
what's good for you like Thrive does all
that work for you
on top of the massive savings on each
order Thrive Market has a deals page
that changes daily that gives us
cashback on so many Brands and they have
a price match guarantee so not only does
thrive Market save us money but they
also save us time we love the filters on
their website there are over 70 so
whether you're looking for certain
certified gluten-free snacks non-toxic
cleaning Essentials you can basically
curate your own shopping experience with
the click of a button and trust that
it's made with the highest quality
ingredients and sourcing methods plus
when you join Thrive Market you're
helping a family in need with their one
for one membership matching program so
you join and they give join in on the
savings with Thrive market today and get
30 off your first order plus a free 60
gift go to thrivemarket.com the toast
for 30 off your first order plus a free
60 gift that's
t-h-r-i-v-e-market.com the toast
thrivemarket.com the toast great thank
you Claudia you're welcome
our first story Wimbledon weekend oh yes
it was a big weekend across the pond at
The Wimbledon tennis match lots of stars
studied the event I would say highlight
Ari was there Ariana Grande spotted that
well milled in but without her wedding
ring which is sparking marriage concerns
from her fans also Brad Pitt was there
Tom Hiddleston Andrew Garfield Jonathan
Bailey it was very star-studded it was
you know Wimbledon is so elevated like
it's just already like the US Open is so
you know like celeb filled and it's very
high brow but like The Wimbledon takes
it up one one level like it's so like
foreign and like I think it's also the
Royal element like there's a royal box
the royal family is always in attendance
in some way and this year George and
Charlotte were there being so cute
yeah but let's talk about Ariana Grande
because one thing I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna forget she's married like she
married you know a civilian so that's
just gonna happen when when that happens
she's not like super public which is
it's usually a good sign
um I'm so I don't know what to think in
terms of her marriage
I'd be lying if I said like I cared so
much like I love Ari but like her
marriage is just like something I like
literally forgot yeah I that makes sense
I just hope that she's okay you know but
the thing is I now that I'm a married
woman like I never wear my ring even
like right now it I don't think it would
fit but um and if it did it would be
very painful but even when it does fit
like I just don't wear it all the time
however if I was going to Wimbledon and
I was a celebrity and people take my
picture and then comment on if I'm still
married or not maybe I would throw it on
but then I would feel like I'm not just
doing it so that people don't you know
what I mean it could really go either
way yeah but I do think
um
it's possible for like a married woman
not to like always be wearing her ring
but like I really wear it every day like
I would say I would argue like most
people do women for some reason men get
a free pass I feel like men wear theirs
every day but I think uh if Ben tried to
take his off he would literally have to
go to the fire department like it would
not come off
I think that's like for most men like it
just doesn't come off that's great but
like for women you take it off because
it's like bigger so nice yeah and you
can't risk it like Ben sleeps in his I
don't but it's like she's not wearing
any rings like maybe she was just having
a minimalist jewelry day I can relate to
that personally no that's possible this
is not a confirmation but it's
definitely you know worth discussing
yeah and I feel like I've seen some
blind items but I don't know if they're
from Duma or antiques I follow them both
on Instagram I think they're empty
that's one of those it's just like not
being a good husband right now
trouble in Paradise well it's worth
mentioning you know we Ari's kind of
been quiet because she's been working
super hard on her role as Glinda the
Good Witch in Wicked the movie which is
supposed to come out in five years
um the strike has obviously caused
delays in that so I don't know if that
means the movie will be even you know
further delayed in terms of its release
which is just annoying
um but so I'm glad she's you know
getting some time off going to Wimbledon
being fabulous sitting with it was
clearly like a celebrity box because
they were all she was next to uh
Jonathan Bailey and behind Tom
Hiddleston like she was you know
yeah in a good spot she was with the
peeps yeah
and she's not really like an out and
about girly these days like she doesn't
really like socialize go go to events so
it was like kind of crazy to see her
there she doesn't do trips to the cape
right her social events calendar is just
like not that booked yeah but it's like
she's filming in London or the UK and
they're not working right now because of
the strike wimbled in is happening why
not Ari
no if I was like a celebrity who would
get invited to like
any sort of a cool event with you know
special privileges like you bet your ass
I'm going yeah no I totally agree
so I loved seeing her out about she
looked gorgeous she's obviously keeping
the blonde hair for Glinda hoping that
the strike will be over soon so she just
gets back into character and I love
seeing her out I don't know what it
means for her marriage but like
again I I don't like to care so much
yeah I would agree with that
and then also Kate Middleton was making
headlines one for slaying yeah again
slayed them once and she'll say them
again she was teary-eyed um as she
watched the final women's match did you
see her crying no no they didn't she had
tears in her eyes it was a very
emotional match I guess because both
women like would like if they had won it
would have been historic both have like
really compelling stories and then for
the one who lost like it was even more
sad because of how far they came well
that's the thing about sports like
they're low-key like always making me
cry like whenever I'm watching anything
on ESPN like they always have some sad
story you know like so I think Kate is
just human and it's nice to see her you
know be one of us for sure and I feel
like that's how people feel but you know
it does probably break Royal protocol
like you never saw Queenie crying that's
so true like not even yeah you're right
like not even at
Diana's funeral I think the boys were
not even crying like outright I'm sure
they were but yeah or they were looking
they go to memorials all the time yeah
so she was obviously overcome however I
didn't think about the protocol I'm sure
I wonder if there's like a loophole
where it's like this isn't an official
public appearance she's just like an
attending an event like even though it's
probably not
done to cry in public as a royal like
it's not like she was at
an official Royal Engagement
being emotional
the thing is anytime one of the royal
family members breaks protocol and it's
like a protocol that's dumb and like a
clearly archaic I think it endears them
to people because you know some some
could say you know I guess like a a
critique they have of the royal family
and mostly Kate is like they're robotic
you know like they're just like not
human and so to see someone you know
feeling emotions that I think a lot of
us have felt watching you know
high-stakes tennis I think it really
humanizes her so if anything I think
it's good for the family I think that
that's how people feel but
um I think this should just be a
one-time thing
no I mean I don't I personally don't
mind it but then then it begs the
question like if you cry for one thing
like then oh you didn't cry for this but
you cried for that you think tennis is
more sad than this you know it's
actually true it's absolutely true it's
a slippery slope
it is well I guess Wimbledon is over
because the guy's thing is over and the
women's thing is over so it was a
fabulous weekend they had their little
like ball last night with the two
winners yeah their picture and I didn't
keep up but like I saw a bunch of stuff
on Tick Tock no back Djokovic she like
wins every year
um and I kind of just have beef with him
like I can't explain why I just like I
don't know I don't I don't like him like
any time I just feel like he's like I
just I have beef with him I can't
explain it I mean he lost so that was
cool
oh I don't have beef with him
and just like his face like bothers me
oh
the person who won Carlos alcaraz yeah
what was his story I didn't follow
anything from the actual tennis super
young you know super green it was like a
really big deal like it was basically
like the old Guard versus the new guard
it was in his speech when he was you
know you have to make a speech in front
of the person you just beat which is
always awkward he was you know saying
how worthy of a competitor Djokovic was
you know what he's been watching
Djokovic since he was born and I don't
think he meant to be Shady but like it
definitely came across a little shady
like calling Djokovic like old yeah it's
hard when you admire someone and yeah
it's so awkward when you did watch them
growing up like there's no kind way to
say it no it's so awkward when like you
beat your hero and it doesn't happen a
lot but like what it does like I
genuinely feel uncomfortable for the
hero yeah but there's no kind way to say
it
yeah no it's true and I think um he was
speaking in English which is not his
first language so he wasn't being like
super PC I don't think Djokovic you know
I don't think he was offended that's
good I feel like when you're
I don't know I feel like it can save his
defense like for the court you know
right right
like Words who can hurt him
no but ever since I started playing
pickleball my um phone obviously knows
that so I've been getting like a lot of
tennis content on tick tock
got it well that's good that Tick Tock
kept you abreast yeah and Kate's outfit
the LA the yeah the green guy the green
the mint green Sublime too much for this
world
Sublime Sublime I wonder where William
was
hopefully getting hair transplant doing
Willy Tings I wouldn't want him to get a
hair transplant it's it's late now but
like they should have been more
proactive you think so I don't think so
I do
I don't think so I feel like I also feel
like it's against protocol like if the
queen had wanted to have a facelift
could she
it's an amazing question I want to say
no because it seems like an uh like a
cosmetic any cosmetic procedure has
um oh because it's potential risks when
you're going under anesthesia I don't
know if you go under anesthesia for um
hair transplant I actually think you
just get like a valium or something you
know I don't think you do but I'm just
saying I feel like there's something
about changing your appearance as a
senior Royal no that's interesting
nail polish a hair transplant is
different than a facelift I think if
Queenie wants to get a facelift like
there might have been some you know red
tape only because it is like a risk at a
certain age or any age to go under
anesthetic like it's just you never know
um so for that reason I could see there
you know being protocol issues but I
don't know I think a hair transplant
might have been safe
like you think they can get BOTOX so yes
I think that at this point like Kate
could get BOTOX as long as like she's
not doing anything drastically radical
looking to the public I I feel like
there's something about like changing or
like what if you want to dye her hair or
any of the kids no that's what I'm
saying he couldn't do it now because
it's so obvious like but if he had
started to lose hair and like they could
see what happened with Charles like
maybe they could have been more
proactive and he'd have a full head of
hair and it wouldn't when nobody would
have ever thought you know Charles has a
nice head of hair though I don't know
I'm just saying like you look at your
ancestry like hair is genetic
got it
I don't know it doesn't bother me so
much like why can't he be bald
like he can he totally totally can and
maybe it's disarming to have like a king
who's not so perfectly handsome like
maybe because you know all human beings
are flawed and it's a way of connecting
with the common man yeah
I don't know when you look back on
photos of a young William he was so
handsome with like his blonde like thick
Luscious Hair and I don't know I just
think maybe I need an AI to put uh
together a photo for me of what Prince
William would look like right now if he
had a full head of hair
and then I'll make my decision I just
feel like if he had a fake full head of
hair like people would clown on him
Jackie hair transplants have come such a
long way I know so many people who have
them you would never know if I told you
some of the people that I know that you
know that have hair transplants you
would never know got it I just want to
say for the record I don't think that he
should have hair transplants or needs
them I think he looks great
and he's aging naturally
not everyone has to be a Kardashian
no no no
but I love those girls too
but it'd be nice if everybody was no I
disagree no I'm totally kidding I'm
obviously kidding okay great
I wonder if Kate could have extensions
good question but she's always had like
hair hasn't been an issue for her she's
always had gorgeous locks or so we
thought
okay are you ready for our next story
yeah
kind of breaking the internet Kylie
Jenner and Jordan Woods reunited they
enjoy dinner together at a sushi
restaurant four years after the Tristan
cheating scandal ruined their friendship
and left the Kardashians fuming the
former best friends dying together at a
sushi restaurant in LA on Saturday night
Daily Mail has photos of it
um they were seen leaving the restaurant
looks like a very casual restaurant the
girl is so gorgeous they're smiling I
think they drove together
like is the Friendship back on
well I have to assume this is not the
first time they're getting back together
you know since the Scandal I'm sure
they've had many conversations or like
Hangouts in private before officially
going into like a public place you're
not going to have like your big reunion
in public so for me this proved that
these two have been in communicado for a
while I'm not sure how long I mean I'm
happy I feel like if I were Jordan I
would be like because Jordan really got
the end of the stick in the whole
thing like I think that the family did
like everything they could in that
moment to like keep Chloe's family
intact because like she did get back
together with him I think there was
really no way they could have even tried
again to be a family true Chloe and
Christian if Jordan was still in the
picture so it's like Jordan had to kind
of take the the the heat
um and I think Kylie was also like a
victim in this too because it was like
completely out of her control she had to
side with her sister of course because
like Jordan was wrong but like that was
like her best best friend so I don't
know this was like such a complicated
mess it's just just reminding me of that
time like when we were in Utah and this
whole thing happened and she went on red
table talking to me to do an emergency
toast like it was so crazy it was so
crazy I do feel like enough time has
passed that like they could move forward
from the incident itself but I feel like
for them the bigger
Fallout is the fact that they haven't
been friends for so long like that's
kind of hard to come back from I agree
that if they're spotted out together I
feel like they called the paparazzi to
get pictures of them together because
it's not like they're at Nobu Malibu
they're it looks like they're in like an
outdoor mall yeah like the sushi
restaurants on the second floor yeah I
also feel like based on what we're
seeing this season on the Kardashians
like the idea of Chloe interested in
getting back together is like so not
ever gonna happen and I think for a
while it was like well they won't they
now it's like settled like these two
people are not going to be together ever
um so it's like it's like a safer
environment for Jordan to come back into
yes I I don't feel like it's like
Tristan was the whole issue like oh if
Jordan's around then Tristan and Jordan
are like you know but it's like so no no
but it's so awkward it's so awkward but
I also think that how the way things
were handled like in the immediate
aftermath
also weren't great on Jordans and I feel
like she probably didn't know what to do
or where to do but one like I actually
had just watched this episode recently
which is why I'm gonna remember it
pretty well but she like wasn't being
entirely honest right after it happened
about like what happened Chloe I think
it was ultimately Tristan who like came
clean about everything and then before
even talking to Chloe or ever talking to
Chloe she went on red table talk
and just like made it bigger and
had this public conversation that like
should have at least been private first
so I think yeah that that also upset the
girls because you really can you can
kiss someone and make a mistake and
you're young yeah of course and you're
out and you're drunk and things happen
no and like now in hindsight it's so not
a big deal
um but that's what time does like Time
Heals but like back then it was so crazy
and it's just really not that crazy and
you know like I think you know in this
whole situation we looked at Jordan as
like the person who the villain like she
did something wrong and like she did for
sure but like now in hindsight like she
was so young Tristan's so much older
than her like she was drunk like it's
like it's you really can just chalk it
up to like make a mistake when you're
really young you know yeah no I feel
like
understood that and we all knew like
this is Tristan's fault the difference
is that like regardless of how badly
Tristan up like he's true's dad
and he's going to come around and he has
to come around like if your friend
betrays you like you don't ever have to
see them again and that's why after a
year like of groveling and apologizing
and being around like if Jordan had been
around for a whole year it would have
been different too but like she they
just went their separate ways
yeah I do also
um
I feel like a lot of people feel this
way because like Jordan obviously like
left the Kardashian universe but she
still was like a public figure
influencer and she seemed so happy she's
in like a really healthy relationship
that's been like going on for many many
years she's like a successful business
person so it's nice to see that like you
know maybe she did need to kind of fly
on her own for a bit like she was always
just like Kylie's sidekick and nothing
really nothing more than that and so in
you know life's most challenging times
like you really Rise Like a Phoenix so I
think it was actually you know all in
all everything that happens for a reason
yeah I would agree with that it's a
really hard lesson to learn and it's
like a hard way to
get a positive outcome but I would agree
that her standing
is great on her own yeah
I don't know how you like actually
reconnect a friendship with someone when
you've literally stopped talking to them
for five years like I don't know closest
to people how awkward
I don't know either you're not related
to this I know on the one hand that's
how I feel like how could you even
forgive like the last five years not
even just like what happened in the
aftermath that like you didn't want to
be my friend for five years but I also
we were just talking about the ceiling
how you could be like so mad at someone
but and then you're like with them and
you remember why you love them and you
have like the best time together and
these two were like sisters in terms of
how well they got along and for how long
and all that anger just sort of lifts
oh a hundred percent but then there's
just the you know the years that have
gone by two people who were you know
very young so what they're 25 now they
were 21 or 20 like you changed so much
so you're literally sitting down with a
person who used to be your sister who
used to live with you and they're so
different they're literally a different
person
I don't think they're so dead I don't
think they're different people than when
they were friends I actually think those
are like transformative years they are
but like these girls are Hollywood girls
they grow up fast I think Jordan is so
different now than the person she was
like the person she was was like
sidekick energy perhaps yes maybe Jordan
but I feel like Kylie's very similar she
was already a baby she's already Kylie
Cosmetics like I feel like
she's grown up more but the same girl
yeah it's just awkward it is awkward but
I'm rooting for these two Chloe posted
like a bunch of her inspirational quotes
last night about forgiveness and healing
so she's fine okay good okay good yeah I
love to check in on Chloe and her
inspirational quotes yeah she'll always
tell you what she's feeling through an
inspirational quote this is one of my
favorite ones that Chloe ever posted and
I believe it was her Instagram bio for
10 years I think we all know it
I crave a love so deep the ocean would
be jealous
and that's our cringy Queen you know
yeah
it is it's giving Sheena Marie Shea like
energy you know with the quotes it
really is
but I'm happy you know everyone seems to
be on good on in a good place with each
other now you know 10 years later
Harmony
another theme of today maybe they were
inspired by streis Fest 2023
perhaps
are you ready for our next story
is it our third or third
cool yeah I'm ready
Ben Platt Cuts an interview obsessed
obsessed with this story then Platt Cuts
an interview short over a nepo baby
question so Ben Platt did an interview
with the Rolling Stone which was
published Friday it was supposed to be
and it was about his new show movie
called Theater Camp and it was cut short
after the reporter asked him about a
past article referring to him as an
apple baby so we all remember the cover
New York Magazine EPO baby they had a
bunch of like babies in cribs and
celebrity heads on them with some of the
biggest nepo babies in the industry the
reporter said you were on the cover of
New York Magazine's natural baby issue
I'm curious what was your response to
that and what did you make of that whole
discourse he responded we're going to
skip right over that if we can
after the reporter confirmed that Ben
had no comment the actors publicist
chimed in to request the interview stick
to his questions about his clients film
Theater Camp then the interview abruptly
ended about halfway through the
predetermined 45-minute time slot
according to the Rolling Stone
okay this is so losery of Ben
Platt like I literally have never had
less respect for an answer in my life
first of all because now we're all
talking about this whereas like if he
had just answered the question I doubt
it would have even gotten picked up if
he had just said Oh I thought it was
funny or whatever like this he made it a
bigger moment which is just bad
publicity second of all like oh my God
it's not that serious like I think and
The Proven track record when we had that
whole nepo baby conversation was like
the people who came out on top were like
the people who laughed at it Gwyneth
Paltrow Haley Baldwin like the people
who you know were in on the joke but to
take yourself so seriously and like Ben
plot is kind of like the number one
example of nepo baby like his dad
literally produced the dear Evan Hansen
movie like it's it's and that doesn't
take away he is what are we always
saying he's literally one of the most
talented people in Hollywood right now
like he's such a star it does not take
away but like my God your dad is
literally a movie producer like you
couldn't have a bigger leg up if you
tried like so to not only
like like deny it but to like avoid
talking about it honestly now it makes
me question your talent like for real
like what are you hiding wow you know
this is so losery I'm such a big Ben
Platt fan like I couldn't have been more
disappointed in this answer if he
tried oh yeah the answer is
disappointing I'm a smaller Ben Platt
fan than you and I actually I feel a
couple different ways about this one I
agree if he just answered the question
said anything it wouldn't have gotten
picked up it's just like buried in a
random interview with like who really
gives who cares I think a part of him is
so entitled that he thought that when he
said like we're not talking about that
in this interview that he thinks
everyone's gonna respect that and that
we would never have heard about it they
accomplished that the journalist would
have felt like weird that they asked the
question they would have just like taken
it from the record and then continued on
with the interview
but I feel like he hasn't gotten a lot
of pushback in his career on anything
because you know he is very talented and
he's an apple baby and he's also very
like industry like he gets invited to
the Met Gala and it's like why you know
no it's so true and I think part of
being like a really big Ben Platt fan is
knowing and like having to just like
live with the fact that you know it's
not confirmed or anything but like there
aren't like amazing stories from fans
interacting with Ben Platt like I've
seen many videos where he denies people
taking pictures like he did like one of
his think he doesn't take pictures with
people he's definitely like not you know
like really grounded and like you know
does it for the fans you know he's kind
of one of those like artsy fartsy like
kind of snobby I do it for the art you
know so you just have to be a Ben Platt
fan and like know that and like just be
okay with it like it's just a kind of
like a fact of life
um and just to be confronted with that
entitlement and like we can't look away
now you know we thus far we've all been
just like kind of ignoring what we what
we know about Ben Platt yeah but I will
say before like if when I think about
Ben Platt as a nepo baby obviously he
has had a lot of doors open for him on
the back end that helped his career but
he is genuinely so talented like even
just he wrote Devin Hansen dear Evan
Hansen he started it before it was ever
a terrible movie that his dad produced
like wait he wrote the play yeah it's
like his play
no I think they wrote it for him I'm
like 90 sure he wrote it for him
um I know it's Patrick and Paul they did
the music yeah
who wrote dear Evan Hansen Stephen
Levinson yes I knew that um I thought he
like created it
no he literally wrote it for Ben Platt
like changes things yeah no but so
undeniably he is undeniably
extremely extraordinarily talented and
none of this you know his it doesn't
take away from that but it is a fact and
so to just ignore it like what are you
doing okay I really thought that he like
was responsible for dear Evan Hansen
I mean he was like the ideation like
it's different to be a talented actor I
mean his singing is really what sets him
apart yeah because I feel like when it
comes to act or nepo babies like a lot
of people could act and it's like really
it's just about opportunity which
nepales have that other people who can
also act don't have yes
so I was just trying to give him credit
as being like a very talented nepo baby
and he is
but like this is really like this is
he's having a bad day and he's also
clearly a diva so it's like yes I think
you know things are flying in his
apartment like things are no 100 and
like now his character I think would be
like called into question and anytime
anybody and this is what happens like
with the cycle of the internet anytime
anybody has had like a negative
interaction with Ben Platt like it will
now reliable again now it's the
Reckoning Ben Platt is overparty right
like that's just what so you really like
once your character gets called into
question everybody gives their opinion
and everybody gives their experience
with you and I don't think he has an
overwhelming amount of like I met Ben
Platt and it changed my life moment you
know yeah
so this was a huge mistake I don't
you're right he probably like is not the
type of person you could like his
publicist would be like listen I think
it would actually just be a better
tactic if we just like announce like if
we just directly addressed it head-on
moving on no one will notice but now and
now we've said it now we're all talking
about it yeah I don't know how what he's
gonna do to navigate out of it like uh
Smith
hope it dies down so awkward I think
he's gonna say something because I think
he's he's probably really struggling
with all this backlash he's never really
had backlash before and you want to know
why I think he's one of the people like
we know you know Dakota Johnson's
parents like he's kind of one of those
never babies who like flew under the
radar for a really long time like people
were like oh my God he's so talented
can't believe he was discovered and like
he was kind of one of those people
because his dad isn't like you know a
Blockbuster movie star he's more behind
the scenes which is just as powerful but
not as recognizable so he really got
away with like people not knowing he was
a nepo baby for like unless you're like
a really big Ben plot fan like you know
but most of the time like I don't think
people really knew and that article kind
of blew it open for him like this it was
kind of this like you know secret-ish
but now it's not because of the article
and the cover I think he was one of the
babies because one of the babies on the
cover yeah so because he really like
that article really kind of flew up like
an exposed it blew up his spot yeah so
of all the people who were named to that
article like he kind of you know it was
the biggest expose on him in my opinion
yeah I think he's gonna put out a
statement and be like I was wanting to
focus on my film Theater Camp we've
worked really hard on this project and I
didn't want no for the castle
director yeah they're always blaming it
on the cast and the girl and the
lighting and craft Services everyone
worked really hard on this project and I
didn't want anything to take away from
it I'm like sorry if that came off you
know in any other way other than trying
to support my movie no and to be honest
if that's what he does like that's such
like low hanging fruit I will be so
disappointed I actually don't think he
will respond I I statement will say
everyone worked really I think there
will be a quote like everyone worked
really hard on this movie no it's
entirely possible that you're right
because and if he does release a
statement he's 100 gonna you know of
course you Gotta Throw the cast and crew
onto the bus
um you wouldn't be a real star if you
didn't
um but I actually don't think he will
respond
I think he will what do you think he's
gonna how is he gonna worm his way out
like he's not he's never been the type
of person who like releases statements
or plays like the game he will just move
on from this but I think everyone did
work really hard on the movie
no I know and what about what about the
cast and crew and I think that's what he
was trying to say when he brutally
rebuffed the journey yeah for sure for
sure but like so shady that they kept
that in like I'm living for it but like
I think a lot of Publications who have
like really good relationships with
certain publicists like they would have
cut that out yeah I wonder why they
wanted to just bury him actually I guess
it's because then the interview ended
and it was like right why we don't have
enough content to end like to like
publish this interview so let's just say
what happened no like let's be real like
an expose not an expose like an you know
90-minute interview or however long it
was 45 minute interview with Ben Platt
about like his movie coming out that
nobody's heard of like
you know this is a business you know
we're trying to get clicks yeah
yeah and I also think his answer is so
indicative of the entitlement that
people like the issue people have with
nepo babies which is that entitlement
and like the way he responded was so
dismissive yeah um it really like it was
the whole issue in in a knot you know
yeah it's it it's very true he could
have just been like I thought it was
really funny I'm so grateful for all the
opportunities that I've had but I also
know that I work really hard and
everybody and everybody on this movie
worked really hard too no and
the thing is like we like a few months
ago we had this nepo baby boom like it
was just nipple baby and so many
different nipple babies spoke out and
certain people got backlash and certain
people were like applauded for how they
responded like Allison Williams on
um watch up inside was really applauded
for for her answer so there's literally
A playbook now like if you want to just
get away unscathed follow the iguanas
Paltrow follow you know there are
certain people who you can follow the
work was done for you the work was
literally done for you you didn't do any
interviews during the time when the nepo
baby boom was happening now a few months
later literally the work has been done
so just choose an answer to copy and do
it yeah it's lazy it's lazy show
business at this point I could see a
world where Ben Platt doesn't think he's
an EPO baby
me too because he believes he's so
talented that that's just a coincidence
that there and I believe I believe a
world in which Ben Platt was born to you
know a father who worked in a factory
and he pursued music and he still got
his famous like yeah the thing is it
really he's undeniably talented so now
it's just like is he a shitty person
that's what that his question is not his
talent is not coming into question now
his character is yeah like he still
could have gotten the lead role as dear
Evan Hansen with no connections yep I I
really believe that's what he tells
himself too and and
so he like it's not like he wants to
make light of the nepo baby thing
because he doesn't identify as one
that's actually a really good point
so that's how Ben sees it
literally
are you ready for our next story
no no no I'm not because you think he'll
ever be ready
yeah give me uh 90 seconds
the next story is brought to you by
ZipRecruiter from pricing to technology
everything that zipper Critter cut does
does for you and what works best for you
so if you're hiring you're currently
dealing with an with economic
uncertainty and now more than ever it's
important to hire the right people
faster and more efficiently to keep
overall costs down thankfully there's a
hiring partner who is focused on you and
your needs and it's zip recruiter and
right now you can try ZipRecruiter for
free at ziprecruiter.com toast here's
how ZipRecruiter prioritizes your needs
they offer straightforward pricing so
you know what you pay before posting
your job so you can stick to your budget
so there's no surprises you're also
reaching more qualified people zip
recruiter is sending your job post to
over a hundred job sites you can find
great candidates faster so their smart
technology identifies the best matches
for your job and you can beat out the
competition for talent ZipRecruiter lets
you invite candidates that you really
want to apply to your job before other
businesses can snag them so hire the
best with the help of a partner who's
All About You zip recruiter you know Jax
and I run a business we know the
importance of hiring the best candidates
the most qualified candidates the people
who you jive with the most and it can be
really really hard to find the right
people but four out of five employers
who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day just go
to our exclusive link to try
ZipRecruiter for free that's
ziprecruiter.com toast again that
ZipRecruiter
ziprecruiter.com toast ziprecruiter.com
t-o-a-s-t ZipRecruiter the smartest way
to hire today's episode is also brought
to you by vegamore we are always trying
to do right by our bodies so when it
comes to our hair and scalp Health
finding a product that actually works
and is made with clean ingredients
always seems like a trade-off but with
vagamore we get products that are made
with clean ingredients and give us
visibly healthy hair and scalp so with
vegamore we are able to have visibly
thicker fuller shinier longer hair
without the wash without the harsh
ingredients all vegamore products are
100 cruelty free and they are never
formulated with potentially harmful
chemicals like parabens or hormones so I
feel like during your first pregnancy
you really got into like the clean
Beauty movement and now you're just like
implementing it in your everyday life
I am personally struggling with like
hair shedding these days and so many
people recommended the grow kit from
vegamore so I've been using it for a few
months now on their value kits like the
grow Essentials kit is when you get to
try more than one amazing product at a
great savings so when you sign up for a
monthly subscription you save more and
you never run low on the products that
you need to take care of your hair
vegamore
grow it has a hair serum that you use
daily I use it daily it goes to your
scalp it does not make your hair oily
you have to be really consistent with it
so like don't forget
um but I love it and it's really um
great to add to your routine if you want
your most beautiful healthy looking hair
vegamore sells one bottle of the grow
serum every 15 seconds on their website
that's how good this stuff is give
yourself the hair you never thought you
could have with vegamore for a limited
time the toast listeners get 20 off
their first order by going to
bigamore.com toast and using Code toast
at checkout that's
v-e-g-a-m-o-u-r.com slash toast code
toast to save 20 off your first order
vegamore.com toast code toast thank you
Claudia our next story have you seen the
new episode of and just like that
oh I started it last night but it was
painful so I stopped okay that's okay
Sex in the City recycles another actor
as Eagle spot Carrie's latest and just
like that love interest is Charlotte's
Randy synagogue Suitor from the 2003 Sex
and the City episode and the actor is
Peter Herman so Peter Herman was in Sex
in the City in 2003 when Charlotte like
had converted to Judaism but broke up
with Harry then she goes to synagogue to
try and meet a nice Jewish boy she meets
Peter Herman who's really nice but makes
her realize like he's not Harry and
he'll never be Harry no but then on this
week's episode Peter Hermann is Carrie's
love interest and he is like not the
same guy he's in the show twice yeah
there are many inconsistencies when it
comes to actors repeating I believe
Justin Thoreau is in it twice as two
completely different characters that
happened on the original series and now
I see on Tick Tock a lot of people
porting out just like random
inconsistencies with the writing from
the new series like in season one Lisa
Todd wexley talked about how hard it was
when her dad passed away and then in
season two um she throws a dinner and
her dad is there so like it's just
you're lying yeah there's so many
inconsistencies
um it's just lazy it is lazy and this
isn't the first time it's happened in
Sex in the City there's a two other
instances
um that they cited and I feel like it
also happened I feel like on friends you
had said
yes it happens a lot on friends but
here's my that guy what's that actor's
name
he's like John Legend
he plays like four different characters
got it well I feel like they know that
this is happening it's not an accident
like Peter Herman could be like by the
way I know I did Sex in the City go to
IMDb 20 years ago he remembers his roles
I feel like in this situation it would
have actually been fine if he played the
same guy and when he meets Charlotte
yeah he should be like oh I think we met
a million years ago at synagogue and
just like reference it because there was
nothing wrong with that guy that he
can't be Carrie's boyfriend now right
okay wait what are the other two um
times that they reference in the article
okay
um AJ Metta who played a waiter who
propositioned Samantha later played
sema's father
oh my God and William a body who played
Tony the Prada guy later sema's love
interest Zed
oh yes yes and he was like a main cat
not a main character but he had like
multiple episodes he would like a lot of
these guys are in one episode out the
next as sema's boyfriend he was in like
four episodes oh cross season one and
two yeah I see him I uh I need to see
him as Tony the Prada guy because I
wonder if he's another one where it like
would have made sense like could this
guy's name be Tony that seem as dating
but this to me feels like really I
because I remember the episode Peter
Herman was in and now he's just like a
nice guy Carrie seeing I'm assuming
um why can't it be the same nice guy
yeah and be like Charlotte like oh I
know him he goes to my synagogue the end
yeah
the end
the end New York is a small town it is I
mean I'm so happy Peter Herman is still
getting work like the way I love that
man would take a bullet for him nine
times over the fact that it's Peter
Herman makes me not upset because it's
like if it were someone else I'd be like
can't you find another actor but with
Peter he's Irreplaceable you can't
he's Irreplaceable
I would put Peter Herman in my show over
and over again he would play every role
he'd literally be like Tyler Perry and
Madea like he would be every single role
Peter Herman's Medea
literally that's how talented this man
is I totally agree and I actually think
he's the perfect Suitor for Carrie like
at this stage in her life based on what
I've seen that by the way I agree I'm
here for all of it especially it's
giving Charles from younger it's giving
Charles from younger I love how Peter
Hermann like is probably such a dynamic
actor and he literally plays the same
role in everything just like wealthy New
York gentleman he's only ever shooting
in New York he's always on SVU he's on
Blue Bloods he's in Sex in the City like
he's exclusively a New York actor no
he's never playing the villain actually
that would be a really good
if you're doing like a thriller cast
Peter Herman as the villain because we
would never see it coming
he's literally America's sweetheart also
Peter Hermann is a Darren star girly
from younger yes and Sex in the City so
I'm sure Darren knew that Peter had been
in Texas City before like it's not this
what this didn't slip through the cracks
they were just like we don't care
right
of New York City television shows Real
Housewives of New York premiered last
night yes I watched up until the first
commercial break because Zach I wanted
to watch and then I went to sleep
um so I didn't see enough to judge it
okay I didn't watch what I saw like I
wasn't you know
Define but it's not fair I saw five
minutes uh I did watch crappy Lake over
the weekend
um with Ben and Brian Jackie I was
cackling like literal belly laughing
these two are just stars and what I
really like
um I feel like shows like that where
it's like Hollywood goes to small town
they really like more often than not
like Will Mock small town wife and
and I don't know it just feels like rude
but what's so interesting is that the
reason they chose Benton Illinois is
like the showrunner I think for
housewives and like for a big production
company is from Benton and he cares so
much about his hometown and they really
never recovered after covid like all the
shops closed there's like no life no
tourism and the people in the town were
like to this showrunner like you know
celebrities like help us and it's it's
so far so complimentary of the town it's
like important to this guy that they
protect like the legacy of Benton and
it's not they're not mocking this way of
life they're not making fun of it and I
really liked that and Luanne and Sonia
are just so game for anything and
they're so funny like we were they're
putting together like an end the whole
they have five weeks there and at the
final week they're gonna put together
like this big you know show out of town
like a talent yeah like talent show and
so they're like
all these people are auditioning and
they're like being so nice like it's
really it's honestly hilarious so far
I'm actually really enjoying it oh wow
I'm shocked I feel like me too first
came out that we said that like
sometimes these shows have a way of just
like making fun of the people who live
there uh yeah and I'm not interested in
watching that but I will take a wreck
from my swirly yeah like if anything the
people who live there like are making
like they're not left we're not laughing
at them you know like they're really all
and they're all being such good sports
like loving Luanne and Sonia and it's
because I think they don't feel
threatened because they know that one of
their alumni from their town is going to
protect their their name that's a nice
setup yeah no it's I was really shocked
um but it's it's so funny like it's
really got that simple life energy but
it's got heart I love that okay maybe
I'll check it out yeah it's cute and
funny there's only two episodes out and
they're like 22 minutes I'll probably
try and finish the new rohoning just so
that I can
fairly assess yeah but
yeah
yeah are you ready for our fifth and
final story
yes a little crazy crime news
crazy crime crazy crime The Man Behind
the viral blue and black dress illusion
you know white and gold yeah I heard
about this I heard about this has been
charged with trying to kill his wife the
Scottish Man Who Rose to Fame in 2015
over his mother-in-law's viral black and
blue or gold and white dress that
divided the internet is now accused of
trying to murder his wife cure Johnston
of the Isle of Colin say appeared at the
high court in Glasgow on Monday after
being charged with the attempted murder
of his wife Grace he had allegedly
committed an 11-year campaign of
domestic violence acts and coercive
control against Grace which allegedly
led to him trying to kill her last March
by pinning her down to the ground and
compressing her neck he denied all
allegations against him including that
he repeatedly assaulted his wife at
their home before brandishing a knife
and attempting to strangle her other
allegations stemming from incidents
between April 2019 and March 2022
include allegedly pushing Grace against
a wall shouting out her shouting at her
and throttling her he allegedly tried to
get into a vehicle she was in and hit
her through an open window as well as
another alleged incident where he put
his wife in a headlock and dragged her
out of a pub after she refused to leave
with him he also isolated her allegedly
from her friends and family as well as
monitoring her money to decide how much
of it she could have access to the
couple became right yeah they became
viral Sensations in 2015 after their
friend and wedding guest posted a
picture to Tumblr uh the the bride's
mother's dress that she wore to the
wedding asking do you see white and gold
or black and blue
all right we'll talk about the dress in
a minute but like this is what's just so
crazy about the internet it's like you
know anyone from anywhere can become
anything and can become a part of
Internet history and you just never
think about them afterwards
um this is such a horrible story like he
literally sounds like
like the worst
like the worst domestic violence abuser
like I've heard like it's 11 years like
and it's all documented and now it like
got to a place where he literally tried
to kill her like literally jail for this
man for life I only wish him the worst I
hope everybody beats him up in jail I
think he's disgusting
what color did you see white and gold
wow okay so I saw black and blue like
and I never I couldn't I was like people
are lying to me and then when it was
like at its peak of virality I was like
drunk in the back of a taxi and like it
came across my feed and for one second I
saw it as white and I was like holy
yeah so the same thing happened to me
like I would look at it all the time
like white and gold you guys are blind
I'm sorry yeah
um but then something like maybe it was
someone's phone next to me where like
the exposure was like different and I
just saw it like through different
lighting and I saw the black and blue so
I saw what you guys were seeing but I
only ever see white and gold
so like now every now and then like the
photo will come up on a meme and be like
throwback and when you see it what color
do you see white and gold
damn I see black and blue that's crazy
it really is the craziest thing no I
know and I hate that it's like now
tainted like I will not support the
dress any longer like like knowing that
the originator of it is quite literally
like such an evil monster like what you
just described is like some of the worst
I've ever heard in my life
I can't support the dress like I can't
no I know dresses over party and
literally hashtag dresses over party
yeah it's messed up they were also on
Ellen like right
it's really sad I hope this woman gets
Justice and honestly I hope he's in jail
for life this is actually a helpful part
of their story because this case is
getting a lot of eyeballs maybe more
than it would have and I feel like there
might be like this call for justice
yeah like no one would be hearing about
this like small case in this small town
um but now it's a global news story and
this man's face and name is everywhere
yeah
so even if he God forbid God forbid
Shalom like gets off his name you know
one Google oh I started seeing this guy
let's Google him boom goodbye boom so we
need to keep his name in The Press yeah
so I thought that was crazy
that is crazy yeah it's just like so
internet
so true well those are the fast five
stories and I feel as though you needed
to know them now let's do a quick TV
recap for the TV show everyone's talking
about that came out on Friday the first
three episodes so annoying of the Summer
I Turned Pretty so much hype so much you
know anticipation and I watched all
three episodes last night I got a bunch
of DMS from people being like please
talk on the toast about like how
disappointing it is
um and here's the thing what did they
say why were they disappointed
people said um like it's clearly not as
good as the first season
um it's cringe now those things might be
true they might but I am certainly
blinded by my obsession with this story
with these characters with this show in
general like I
like I actually I can't not like it and
I'm sure I know there are moments that
were cringe like I know I don't care
like it was so good but I will say I
think one of the last things and one of
the biggest things from last season that
people were obsessed with were the music
and I don't even think the people who
were putting the music soundtrack
together like tried that hard like I
just think they did you know what felt
right but now because the music became
such a big thing there was so much
anticipation for the music that it
actually felt like a lot of the music
selection to be so obvious to the point
where it was like lame like she gets in
her car and they're playing driver's
license like come on you can do better
than that no and it's like they did this
whole montage of her driving and crying
just so they could play the song and
it's like it's
it's a little heavy-handed and also I
feel like she's so young does she have
her license or she like just got it okay
I feel like crying and driving like I
just took my job it's so dangerous they
said like you really shouldn't drive in
a really emotional state no so dangerous
it's so true like no wait so that just
stuck out to me but no it did feel like
they put in this whole three-minute cry
scene in the car just so they could play
the song and I agree with you like maybe
they got some natural organic
interest in the in the soundtrack but
now they're choosing the most obvious
songs I want to say first of all except
when it's snowing on the beach they
don't play Snow on the beach I'm
actually glad they didn't because that
then I would have been sitting here
being like and it's snow on the beach
and it's snow on the beach like I
actually liked I liked Invisible String
okay I maybe because I love that song
when she said it's snowing on the beach
and then like a song comes out I'm like
snow on the beach like it actually
bothered me that it wasn't like you're
gonna be so obvious the whole time at
least like give me that okay and then
the Moment Like Music wise that
everyone's like obsessed with I don't
know if you got to it it's like we
finally see what happened at the funeral
like it wasn't even that crazy
um but he like said Conrad said
something really mean things to her like
I know I knew I never should have
started seeing you like you know you're
so dramatic immature and in the
background yeah it was really mean in
the background
um they're playing Silver Springs which
is Fleetwood Mac
um and it's a song that's you know super
popular but it's had like a real
Renaissance with you know the the Gen Z
crap out on Tick Tock and it's all about
like you will never get away from the
sound of a woman that loves you like
it's this woman scorned she wrote it and
she you know what's her name Stevie
Nicks wrote it about you know the guy in
her band she was with forever and he has
to come on stage and sing the song
that's literally about him and people
are like yes female empowerment whatever
so it's having like a whole Renaissance
I love love love love love love love
love that song to see these two 15 year
olds like standing in a funeral like it
was so honestly like it didn't everyone
was like wait till you get to Silver
Springs and honestly like it was cringe
as like it's just like a really
mature song it's a really serious song I
don't know it was like a little too
dramatic for me so the thing is what I
one of the best things about the show
last season was the music and I think
they know that and they're just trying a
little too hard like the music
selections are just like really like
kind of like ever heard of subtlety like
they're obvious and corny and also I
feel like some of the greatest shows
that would have like music
accompaniments like what I think of
obviously not the greatest shows but
like the OC and Gossip Girl it was a mix
of like popular music at the right time
and also like songs you've never heard
before that now you're looking up on
Spotify and you're listening to over and
over again and like they're literally
choosing like top 10 hits no Jackie they
had a One Direction song I know steal my
girl and by the way I love that song I
love One Direction but it's just like
it's so obviously is taking her away for
the night he stole this girl and he's
like really is like stealing her from
Jeremiah you know they're subtext like I
just have text you're generous I just I
thought it was like a little too obvious
now having said that I still like ate up
every minute of the show like I
absolutely love the show I love belly I
love Conrad like I'm such a Conrad girl
I and I by the way not Taylor having
like a main role this season I actually
really like Taylor
um I like I know that the show is flawed
and like people are critiquing it and
they're 100 right but like you're really
not gonna find me disliking it okay so
what I'll say is I don't remember what
my takeaway from the first season was
but I must have liked it enough because
I watched the whole thing and I only
felt warmly towards it so I put on the
next season on Saturday and I just hated
how it started they just like the whole
thing is in between flashbacks and
present day and she's just like so
miserable obviously but like we don't
understand what's going on was the book
like that
I don't know but the thing is I
definitely feel like I'm enjoying the
show a lot more because it's a surprise
to me because I know everything so I'm
just seeing how they're like taking I
know but I'm just saying what happened
at the funeral like stop saying
the funeral the funeral like well at
least they didn't make us wait like
Eight Episodes we find out in the third
episode okay cool I'll I'll catch that
later
um so I just like wasn't loving the tone
or the pace
um I also have to keep in mind like the
show is not meant for me I'm twice
belly's age so it's okay if the tone and
the pace don't work for me it's a
lighthearted like pretty show
um but I feel like so much of the magic
from the first season was like cousins
in the sun and the beach yes they're
running and like instead I'm in like a
smelly old classroom now well that
happens in the books too it's like you
just need them to go back to cousins
because it's so magical but you know
life happens in the school year so
they're not always at cousins and like
it's definitely annoying yeah and
everyone's just like a little depressed
right now so it's it's like it's at a
it's a low but they're allowed to be
going through stuff so I just wasn't
obsessed with what I saw so far but I'll
keep watching because it's you know well
made and they work hard on it the cast
and crew and the lighting right yeah the
lighting is really nice it is it's
really beautifully done but everyone's
like quaking over the music and of
course like Taylor Swift
doing her thing on the uh soundtrack and
agreed it was just too obvious
and I wasn't it wasn't stirring emotion
you know it's like Back to December and
it's Christmas lights like it's just so
obvious and like I love hearing Taylor
that's what I loved about the first
season is how much they embraced Taylor
but it was like these deep cuts of
Taylor it wasn't obvious you know it's
not like they played love story when
when Conrad got up to dance with her at
the ball like they played the way I
loved you like a random deep cut so it
wasn't so obvious and I loved that I'm
like oh my God not literally like the
most deep cut my favorite random song so
I don't know it's just I think they got
a little cocky with the music yeah I
agree they need to dig a Little Deeper
yeah
also
what was I gonna say oh like one of my
favorite Parts about season one was
Steven and Shayla yes and shayla's gone
she had we I knew she wasn't gonna be in
the season because she posted on her
Instagram a few months ago and she also
made it seem like it wasn't her choice
right so I've already what happens with
Stephen in the books where would he be
at shayla's not even in the books Steven
is not as much of a main character in
the books as he is in the show he's just
like this older brother who's like
always mean to Melly like always
that's annoying because he was one of my
favorite characters this season like
he's hyped up on the speech that he made
his valedictorian that I thought yeah
that sucked yes
um and like is it am I supposed to be
shipping him and Taylor because I do yes
yeah you are and I believe
um that we're like all supposed to be on
board yeah because he like looked at her
at the party and then tried to crowd
Surf and embarrass himself
um but I feel like he's clearly so
jealous of the boyfriend right and
Taylor's the cute sweet girl and I
should yeah and she's a good friend in
the book like we're annoyed with her
because like she comes to cousins and
it's like get the out like you're a
school friend this is a summer friend
yeah even last season we were annoyed by
her and then she was like throwing
herself at Steven but I love Shayla so
I'm like what are you doing yeah
she is a good friend and she's like very
smart and she's the exact sort of friend
that like belly needs to get her out of
her comfort zone but doesn't like peer
pressure her and just understand belly
it's so true she's really like the
perfect friend for belly yeah
so I'm enjoying I mean now episodes are
being released once a week so I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna sit around and wait
like some sort of I will I'll
see you guys in six weeks okay cool I'll
watch whenever you watch then
yeah I'm just like uh it's a type of
show it's like I need to watch it in one
sitting it's not like something that I
can really wait for week to week yeah
like what do I look like
yeah
so that's our show
tears
and that's all she wrote so thank you so
much for listening to the test Monday
morning everybody Friday on YouTube so
if you're watching this on YouTube
please don't forget to subscribe give
this video a thumbs up we're still
available
talented we are hope you guys have an
amazing Monday don't forget to rise and
Grand and we'll see you tomorrow bye
love you bye